so the first thing you should do in
order to minimize network latency is to
minimize the number of http requests and
a major major way to do this is to avoid
page redirects
each redirect can cause a dns lookup a
tcp connect and the sending of the
actual http request itself all over
again https has even more round trips
per connection so you're looking at high
hundreds of milliseconds per redirects
as a penalty at least
if you have a legitimate need for
redirects for example if you've moved a
resource that's great but use a 301
redirect if you can lots of browsers
will actually update links then
you also want to eliminate render
blocking resources like waiting on
multiple style sheets or fonts or the
like anything that forces the browser to
wait for another http transaction to
complete before it can render the app is
going to be much more noticeable on
mobile so combine and minify those style
sheets kids
this also includes avoiding blocking
rendering by waiting for the download of
javascript files if you can use async or
defer on script to let the content
render as soon as possible
in short you want to prioritize the
network transactions of whatever you
need to render the initial page full of
content
make sure you're loading images on that
first page first before ones that may be
down in the bottom of the page
get that first page on the screen as
quickly as possible you should obsess
over the network page in the developer
tools to make sure you're loading items
in the correct order